un mine bientôt cinq ans pilote de
karting
son papa est un passionné de sport auto
il lui a très vite transmis ce virus
l'emmener sur les pistes et j'ai tout de
suite qu'il a aimée quoi du coup il
s'est assis dans un kart happy day qui
s'est assis dans un quartier n'a pu il a
plus voulu sortir d'une carte en fait
quelqu'un que je connais une folle
course qui du coup avait un kart et
qu'il a adapté à sa taille
voilà il m'a prêté et puis on m'a tant
que j'achète celui-là il à robecq
épisode on a commencé sa partie des
parkings au circuit du centre val de
loire notamment où tout a commencé
mais qu'ils le peuvent père et fils vont
rouler aujourd'hui journée privée à 4
karting un circuit kamin découvre les
responsables de la piste eux découvrent
le phénomène un petit peu tard du
confort et prennent plus tôt pour
prendre l'extérieur
le panther des ressortir bien large je
pense déjà qu'il a du potentiel par
sylla du tout pas peur de la vitesse on
voit qu'il est vif
après il reste pas mal de choses à
travailler notamment les trajectoires
le freinage est également le regard qui
est aussi important aux tartines au fil
des tours le chrono des 153 le tour
d'aman 53 donc c'est son meilleur tour
de la langue amine n'a pas encore l'âge
de faire des compétitions en france mais
il a déjà tout l'équipement nécessaire
mais qu'est ce tu fais là commence à
s'habiller un pilote fait moi voir tout
ce que tu as tout ce qu'il faut pour
être un pilote qu'est ce qu'il faut
avoir en vain guichard une combi jaune
photo de couilles en cash qu'une cagoule
et pourquoi faut avoir tout ça tout ça
c'est pour se protéger
il a enchaîné les tours et le chrono est
encore descendu quinzaine dont tu
triches tutrice combat 50 52 9 est ce
que toi tu veux battre des records
est ce que tu as des pilotes préférés ce
que tu peux me donner des noms de
pilotes de formule un où deux voitures
dis-moi dis-moi schumacher lewis
hamilton j'éteigne chalon
certains des pilotes soutiennent et
encouragent amine déjà présents sur les
réseaux sociaux
celui que certains surnomment le wind
lewis hamilton son préféré est à
surveiller de très près
[Musique]